yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the first
full official Avengers infinity war
trailer for Easter eggs and other
interesting details you might have
missed if you're new to my channel I do
regular comic book movie videos and to
celebrate the infinity war trailer
finally dropping and kicking off a new
superhero giveaway for all my
subscribers I've got full details on
that plus the winners of my Justice
League giveaway later in this video
we're gonna kick off with Bruce Banner
because not only does his first shot in
the trailer give us a very cool Easter
egg but also because since Mark Ruffalo
joined the MCU in the first Avengers
movie he's given us the awesome big
screen banner and Hulk I've always
wanted in the infinity war trailer we
see Bruce Banner back on earth where it
looks like he's crashed through the
ceiling of dr. Strange's sanctum
sanctorum as the Hulk and smashed
through the floor it reminds me of
banners crash landing in the Avengers
movie when he met Harry Dean Stanton the
security guard this scene is a very cool
nod to the first issue of the Infinity
Gauntlet comics in which Silver Surfer
crashes through the roof of dr.
Strange's sanctum sanctorum to warn of
Thanos's impending arrival this is very
likely also banner arriving back on
earth to warn the Avengers about Thanos
because if you recall at the end of Thor
Ragnarok Hulk was with Thor when Thanos
his sanctuary ship arrived to intercept
the god of thunder ship also notice in
this shot that Tony Stark is holding a
little phone and it looks like it could
be the same one that cap had FedExed to
him at the end of Captain America Civil
War talking of Bruce Banner we have an
intriguing shot later in the trailer of
him and will Candice standing next to a
huge Hulk buster arm later again we see
the Hulk Buster which looks different
than last time we saw it and it's in
action in Wakanda and it feels like
there's a hint here that we may see
Bruce Banner getting into the Hulkbuster
for infinity war rather than Tony Stark
there are other possibilities too though
and I wonder if it could be T'Challa
sister Shuri in the suit we already know
that Sheree is an engineering and
robotics expert with skills as her on a
par with Tony Stark also in that huge
work and embattled Hulk is already there
without any suit and I can't see Sheree
in that lineup and on top of that we've
already seen an important work hand and
character suit up in black panther style
Hulkbuster armor in the comics also look
a bit more closely at this amazing line
up because cap has some interesting arm
shields I think
could be some cool work and and tech
that's been designed for him and of
course after cap abandoned his shield at
the end of civil war I just loved Black
Panthers line get this man a shield so I
wonder if that smart work hand and tech
could make a shield materialize in a
similar way to how Black Panthers suit
appears here also notice how Captain
America no longer has his star on his
costume which is understandable given
that after the events of Civil War he's
now a fugitive on the run
that's Plus Steve Rogers beard
symbolized his changed role in the MCU
and are a nod to the comics where he
took on a new identity as Nomad when he
took off his Captain America costume
after becoming disillusioned due to the
corruption of the US government
as for his beard that seems like a hat
tip - Captain America's cast away in
dimension Zed storyline in the comics
there's also a very quick shot in the
trailer of Steve Rogers catching a spear
from one of thanasis Black Order that
figure which we only get a glimpse of
here is Proxima midnight who in the
comics was sent by Thanos to retrieve an
infinity gem and in the trailer it looks
like we see Proxima plus one of her
Black Order comrades Corvus glaive
attacking visions mine stone like cap
Black Widow is also sporting a new look
in infinity war her change from red hair
to blonde is likely because like cap
she's had to go underground to lie low
from the authorities when we last saw
Natasha in Civil War she'd switch sides
from Team Iron Man to help cap escape at
the Berlin Airport and Tony Stark later
warned her that the government would be
coming for her now I think we can all
agree the battle in Wakanda looks pretty
epic and is a huge hint that Thanos is
after something they're most probably
the soul stone and if you're wondering
what those four armed creatures are well
they're outriders in the comics
outriders are genetically engineered
beings used by Corvus glaive and Thanos
to scout out worlds for tributes for the
mad Titan the outriders like their own
free will and are essentially cannon
fodder for their masters the trailer
also reveals a battle in New York with a
huge portal like ship or generator
appearing over New York and this is
where we get an awesome shot of Spider
Man who's now wearing the iron spider
suit he turned down at the end of Spider
Man homecoming Spidey seems to fail at
stopping whatever is going on here
getting a beating from Thanos but I
wonder whether the next shot of Thor and
another
huge circular object could be the god of
thunder inside the heart of whatever is
driving this generator okay let's look
at vision and Scarlet Witch now we know
already that vision gets attacked for
his mind stone but earlier we get to see
him together with wander and what's
curious is that were seeing him for the
first time with a human face although it
looks like he's still got the yellow
mine stone in his forehead I wonder if
he has the ability to switch between
Android and human form
also notice that vision appears to be
sharing a room with wander a big hint
that we're seeing their relationship
progressed from just cooking paprikash
together to something a lot more serious
another nod to how the couple also got
together in the comics by the way a
small thing I noticed is that we never
actually see Corvus glaive extract the
mind stone from vision so I wonder
whether there's a chance the black order
here could be manipulating the stone
leaving it in vision and placing him
under their control so what about the
other two stones we see in Thanos's
Infinity Gauntlet in the trailer well
the blue stone will be the space stone
which we see Loki offering up to Thanos
this scene very likely happens on board
the ship that Loki and Thor are on at
the end of Thor Ragnarok and his strong
confirmation that Loki stole the
tesseract from Odin's treasure room on
Asgard at the end of that movie you can
see the carnage that Thanos has
inflicted onboard the ship because these
are scarred Ian's body markings match
those from as Guardians in the last Thor
film although Loki is probably trying to
save his own skin here I wonder whether
there's a chance he's offering up the
stone to save the remaining us Guardians
as well and the purple stone that Thanos
already has will be the power stone
which was given to the Nova Corps for
safekeeping by the guardians of the
galaxy there's a shot in the trailer of
Thor looking out over a planet which
seems to be burning I think it could
actually be Xander home with the Nova
Corps and therefore show the aftermath
of Thanos is attack so in the trailer we
have an idea of how phallus has got hold
of three of the six Infinity stones he's
after but there's obviously three more
he has to get the reality stone the soul
stone and the time stone and I may do a
video with more details on where we can
expect to see those by the way another
cool detail you might have missed is
that the word spoken by Nick Fury and
the other Avengers at the start of the
trailer were actually originally spoken
by Nick Fury in the first Avengers movie
there was an idea
Starck knows this the idea was to bring
together a group of remarkable people
see if they could become something more
see if they could work together when we
needed them to to fight the battles that
we never could there was an idea to
bring together a group of remarkable
people to see if we could become
something more so when they needed us we
could fight the battles that they never
could and Marvel also sneakily includes
those words in their written form in the
current Marvel Studios intro so does the
infinity war trailer live up to your
expectations and were there any other
cool Easter eggs or details you spotted
make sure you leave a comments about the
trailer below and subscribe for a chance
to win a cool superhero Funko pop the
winners from my Justice League giveaway
are on screen right now and if that's
you make sure you send me a private
message with your details so I can get
the prize out to you if you enjoyed this
don't forget to hit that like button
turn on notifications for all my new
videos and check out some more of my
Marvel and other superhero videos right
here thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers